aber selbst der historische praxis hat
in dieser woche in sachen
nachrichtenwert absolut keine chance
gegen das corona virus ja gestern hat
die der ist wirklich los ist was war
gestern hat die vero den internationalen
gesundheitsnotstand ausgerufen sagt aber
auch ausdrücklich es besteht weiter kein
grund zur panik
tatsache ist über 10.000 menschen haben
sich in china infiziert wo man
inzwischen zu relativ rigiden maßnahmen
greift viele aufnahmen zeigen
nachbarschaftskomitees die menschen in
ihrer wohnung festsetzen
diese personen kommen aus johann bitte
nicht besuchen steht auf dem zettel den
sie neben der tür anbringen
ja ich sag mal millionen bürger einfach
abriegeln das funktioniert auf dauer
nicht haben wir in deutschland auch mal
probiert sie kommen irgendwann rüber das
ist
man kann versuchen 10
unser haushalt ist ja so in der stadt
wuchern in china fahren keine
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel mehr das
öffentliche leben ist derartig zu mehr
leben gekommen nun überlegt schon woran
umzubenennen in hannover jetzt ist jetzt
ist mal ganz im ernst
gesundheitsnotstand hin oder her hin
oder her so eine normale grippe ist wohl
doch weit gefährlicher und selbst für
die deutschen die dann noch in den
betroffenen regionen in china ausharren
gibt es ja jetzt eine lösung angeblich
plant man dafür die bundeswehr zu
schicken ein bis zwei jets der luftwaffe
die möglicherweise bereits morgen oder
auch am donnerstag in die region fahren
sollten liegen sollen juni fahren war
schon richtig heiß
es sind jets der bundeswehr am ende
und auch wenn der krankheitsverlauf in
den allermeisten fällen bis jetzt sehr
sehr mild ist auch bei den patienten in
deutschland gerade bei denen kann man
sich nur wundern welche auswirkungen so
ein virus weltweit haben kann auch das
ist ja globalisierung flüge werden
eingestellt
fluggesellschaften fliegen da gar nicht
mehr hin dass werden fabriken
geschlossen mit anderen worten die
eigentlichen opfer dieses virus sind wie
immer die börsianer
also es sei denn
es sei denn man hat rechtzeitig die
richtigen aktien gekauft ich habe
glücklicherweise zwei aktien mit anti
grippe viren schon im portfolio oder 1
mit hiv-medikamenten ja auch hier moment
und pankraz verlangen gewarnt werden und
eins mit einem grippevirus das heißt ich
habe mir mein portfolio schon die
richtigen aktien drin dafür
ich habe mir solche sorgen gemacht um
den ball so und dann hat dieser corona
virus leider noch eine ganz schlimme
nebenwirkungen nämlich
verschwörungstheorien müssen sie
wirklich mal googeln wenn sie mit ihrem
leben nichts besseres vor haben sie
müssen wir googeln was da gerade alles
durchs netz geistert bill gates hat das
virus in einem seiner labor gezüchtet um
jetzt mit einem gegenmittel geld zu
verdienen habe ich gelesen würde zu bill
gates pass niemand
er hat uns auch schon mit windows 8
gequält also wer weiß es ist natürlich
alles quatsch freunde hier die wahre
wahrheit
das kroner geheimnis und wie so viele
undurchsichtige geschichten beginnt auch
diese mit johannes b kerner zdf show
liest gern diese nichts ahnende
schildkröte an absichtlich
wahrscheinlich kurz darauf stirbt das
tier und landete die meisten
schildkröten in der fleisch wusste
berüchtigten firma bilke und wer ist bis
heute für sein leben gern willkür brust
genau peter altmaier
ungeklärt ist nur wie das virus danach
auf diesen süßen lemuren überspringen
konnte
denselben lemuren übrigens der kurz
danach einen früher anderen aus der
uckermark belästigt wird
die nur stunden später bei einem
zoobesuch mit dem chinesischen
staatspräsidenten einen panda bären an
hustet das augenblicklich infizierte
tier überträgt das virus schließlich
auch sein unschuldiges baby und was ist
eine besonders beliebte vorspeise im han
china genau baby panda salat
vielen dank johannes b kerner
die wahrheit ist
si
immerhin heißt es allenthalben immerhin
deutschland ist vorbereitet auf solche
wären und das sehr gut zu wissen
andererseits sind aber speziell unsere
deutschen notaufnahmen schon seit jahren
chronisch überlastet auch ganz ohne
krone wie schaut mal live rüber in die
notaufnahme einer unfallklinik in köln
chorweiler zu dr birte schneider frau
doktor wie lange sind sie da jetzt schon
im dienst
gute frage ich arbeite seit ich spiele
jetzt seit januar keine ahnung ist ja
sowieso immer die hölle los aber dank
der korona berichterstattung kommen wir
gar nicht mehr nach hause
jeder der zwei mal liest oder viermal
fox denkt er hätte corona vielen dank
deutsche medien wir versuchen
aufzuklären
wachsam bleiben ist extrem wichtig wir
reden alle nur noch von den virus virus
man kriegt kompanie für die meisten geht
alter natürlich normal weiter wie hier
auf der spielwarenmesse in nürnberg
auch aussteller aus china sind vor ort
beunruhigt das nicht frei laufen die
chinesen
aktuelle studien sagen schon drei
minuten sat 1-frühstücksfernsehen töten
mehr gehirnzellen als ein
durchschnittlicher sat 1 zuschauer
insgesamt
so leute alle die denken sie hatten
corona gehen jetzt bitte nach hause man
ernsthaft ich behandle nur noch leute
mit einem richtigen problem die
deutschen rennen wegen jedem ist in die
notaufnahme was haben sie ich krieg das
gurkenglas nicht aus musste ich machen
der als privatpatient härtel bei der
ganzen corona history geht das
eigentliche problem unter die
überlastung im sogenannten normalbetrieb
neue zahlen über ein fünftel der
deutschen klinikärzte arbeitet 60
stunden die woche 60 das ist ja wahnsinn
unverantwortlich ja klar irgendwann
machst du dann natürlich film weil du
kaputt bist hier
ich habe an diesem man eben eine halbe
stunde lang eine vaginale ultraschall
untersuchung durchgeführt
und er hat nichts gesagt weil das geil
fand
doch doch
erklären sie doch woher kommt denn diese
überlastung ganz einfach weil deutsche
krankenhäuser seit den nuller jahren
gewinne erzielen soll heißt immer
weniger personal muss immer mehr
patienten versorgen und lukrative
operationen kriegen wir oft nur bezahlt
wenn wir eine mindestzahl erreichen wenn
sie jetzt als klinik nur bezahlt werden
wenn sie 50 knie operieren im jahr und
haben 49 geschafft
da brauchen sie 50 das heißt es ganz
sein dass dann die indikationsstellung
ein wenig lockerer werden
so ist das kommst du mit einem
eingewachsenen fußnagel und gehst mit
den neuen knie gleichzeitig sind aber
17.000 pflege stellen unbesetzt
kurz gesagt für meinen burnout bin ich
auf corona gar nicht angewiesen
der nächste happy nein sie haben kein
corona und ich gehe jetzt nach hause
[Applaus]
und alles sobald wir eine million
abonnenten liebe liebe liebe fans ich
würde mich so was schon freuen wenn ihr
ein abo dallas auch er würde den gern so
was von glücklich machen